ah
hola hola a todos creo que yo soy la
única que no traje apoyo visual porque
estaba preparándolo y me dije sería una
contradicción porque lo que yo quiero es
esto es todo lo que necesitamos para
imaginar una pluma tinta un libro es lo
que necesitamos realmente para van a ver
para saber quién es quiénes somos los
guardias los que están aquí a los que
están en sus casas o donde quiera que
estén si van manejando no lo hagan que
se paren parece por favor y que intenten
guardar el equilibrio en un solo pie
ya que lo consigan cierren los ojos
les garantizo que inmediatamente todos
comenzaron a temblar ya sé que lo
hicimos muy rápido después lo pueden
hacer en sus casas o tuvieron que bajar
el pie o tuvieron que abrir los ojos
está científicamente comprobado que
quien tiene que bajar el pie y no puede
guardar el equilibrio cuando cierra los
ojos es una persona herida
fracturada que carga algún vacío ya se
pueden sentar perdona que carga algún
vacío que tiene alguna perdida
lo que les acabo de decir de lo
científicamente comprobado no es cierto
recuerden que soy novelista y lo que me
gusta y para lo que me pagan es para
contar mentiras lo que sí es cierto lo
que sí es cierto es que todos los seres
humanos yo creo que el 100 por ciento
vamos por la vida con alguna herida con
alguna fractura con algún dolor con
alguna pérdida por eso es una maravilla
esto del 15 porque porque un jarrón
podríamos tirarlo pero no podemos andar
tirando por la vida los seres humanos no
nos podemos tirar a nosotros mismos
aunque a veces nos dan ganas
y las letras curan después y como me di
cuenta las letras realmente curan la
lectura y la escritura curan y reparan
las heridas no tratan de disimular las
no es que el jarrón tenga otra vez que
ser perfecto y que no se vea
que está roto al revés es abrazar
nuestras heridas nuestros vacíos
nuestros duelos nuestros rencores
nuestros arrepentimientos para hacerlos
parte de nosotros mismos les voy a
contar cómo llegué yo este mundo de la
imaginación y las letras
tengo una mamá educadora especialista en
problemas de aprendizaje
además pintora que todos los días a lo
de la comida nos contaba un cuento a mí
ya mis hermanos un cuento que ella
inventaba ese día a esa hora y lo
maravilloso es que nosotros le decíamos
quiero que se trata de tal cosa con
tales personajes si ese día alguien me
había goleado en la escuela obviamente
iba a ser el malo del cuento y acababa
en la cárcel entonces era una maravilla
todos los días a la hora de la comida
escuchar una historia nueva y tengo un
padre afortunadamente los dos siguen
vivos un padre que le encanta la música
que quería ser director de orquesta pero
bueno un padre de director del que está
encerrado en un cuerpo de contador
público que todos los fines de semana o
nos llevaba un concierto o nos ponía
música beethoven o mozart bach y nos
decía cierren los ojos e imaginen que
les hace sentir la música y ahora que
recuerdo cuando estaba viendo el tema el
15 que yo creo que mi mamá sin saberlo
hizo un poco de kim suyo y les voy a
contar brevemente mi hermano que era y
sigue siendo muy travieso con algún
gancho rayo la puerta de la entrada de
la casa de una puerta muy grande una
puerta de madera y se veían los rayones
y yo no sé si en esa época no teníamos
dinero para arreglarlo mi mamá decidió
esperarse un poco pero empezó a contar
un cuento a partir de eso cuando
llegaban mis amigos les decía que hacía
mucho tiempo cuando ayer un bebé había
nevado mucho imagines en la ciudad de
mexico en las afueras donde vivíamos que
había nevado tanto que había caído nieve
ya cerca de la casa y que ya había ido
un día al súper
había dejado la puerta abierta sin
querer se le había al bat había tratado
de cerrar se le abría se había distraído
había dejado la puerta abierta y había
bajado una loba había entrado ávido a mi
recámara y se había robado este bebé
está este moisés una canasta donde yo
estaba
obviamente mi mamá llegó del súper de
las pisadas de la loba entra corriendo
ve que no estoy
casi le da un ataque de histeria lalami
para palear a la policía
siguen las huellas logran encontrar la
cueva encuentran a la loba y se dan
cuenta que lo único que había pasado es
que la había perdido un lobezno y solo
quería sustituir esta maternidad conmigo
esto es todo lo que le contaba mi ama a
mis amigos y yo veía la cara de mis
amigos y decía guau porque abrían los
ojos y me daba cuenta del poder de la
palabra y del poder de la adicción y de
los cuentos pero aún así como que no
podían querer muy bien que estuviera
realmente pasado y yo les decía claro
qué pasó vengan y les mostraba
las garras de la loba en la puerta
finalmente así crecí crecí entre
historias entre adicción acabando la
preparatoria a los 17 años tuve la
suerte de poder mirar a parís a vivir un
año y ahí conocí a un profesor de
literatura de la sorbona que me enseñó
todavía más el poder de las letras me
regaló este libro los alimentos
terrestres de andrei y que se volvió en
mi libro de cabecera desde ese entonces
hasta ahora es un libro que yo empecé a
leer y empecé a subrayar me di cuenta lo
importante que es apropiarse de los
libros lo subrayaba y después copiaba
las frases subrayadas en un diario que
yo tenía y si es un libro muy importante
porque es un libro que invita a la
rebeldía que invita a no conformarse que
invita a cuestionarse que invita a
romper esquemas y encontrar los suyos
propios y hasta ese entonces yo tenía
una vida digamos color de rosa con una
familia unida con los padres que me
apoyaban que me daban libertad que
confiaban en mí
regreso a mexico y empiezan las rupturas
y las grietas en mi abuela materna un
día decide que se quiere suicidar y
muere en el intento ya sé que soy
extraño decidió que se quería suicidar
dejo su carta de despedida salió en la
ciudad de mexico
se quería tirar de un puente sobre la
calzada de tlalpan
esto que les estoy diciendo es real no
es mentira yo creo que fue tal su
impresión al ver hacia abajo que le dio
un infarto y cayó muerta sobre sobre el
puente no se llegó a tirar pues por eso
digo que se quería suicidar y murió en
el intento después la mejor amiga de mi
mamá que era mi tía favorita la mujer
con quien yo me quedaría si mi mamá
faltará por querer estar delgada y
cumplir con las expectativas sociales se
emite una dieta terrible le dan unas
gotitas que no le van a hacer nada más
que adelgazar la y muere de un infarto
mi mejor amiga tenía dolores de cabeza
algún médico decidió sin estudiarla que
era una migraña el inyecto contra el
dolor y dos semanas después murió de un
aneurisma dejando una huérfana de tres
años
mis padres que era la pareja perfecta se
divorcia yo me caso y me divorcio en fin
fue una época de muchas de muchas
muertes de duelos hasta llegar
al primero de abril del 2019 ese día mi
mejor amigo amiga compañero o compañera
era realmente para mi nombre muy
importante amaneció colgado de un árbol
a tres cuadras de su casa y lo peor de
todo bueno lo peor evidentemente lo peor
fue que se haya se haya decidido
quitarse de la vida pero el día anterior
él me habló por teléfono y no le pude
contestar porque estaba en un avión al
aterrizar le mandé un wash y me dijo no
puedo contestar en estos momentos porque
estoy con mi abogado te llamo y yo no
insistí ni le marqué llegué a mi casa me
dormí y al día siguiente me despierta su
manager y me dice oye no encontramos a
armando
le dije pues no sé dónde está y me dijo
te ven mejor o si tú no sabes dónde
están nadie más va a saber dónde está y
al ahora me llegó un watts de ella que
me dijo ya apareció está muerto esto no
sólo fue el el duelo y la pena y el
vacío sino la culpa y los hubieras
porque no le contesté porque no insistí
porque no le de importancia porque no lo
vi desde antes este amigo era armando
vega-gil
músico fundador de botellita de jérez un
gran poeta un gran escritor publicó más
de 20 libros
evidentemente un gran gran amigo un gran
fotógrafo y un hombre que según yo
gozaba la vida por eso fue tan tan
triste tanto también más fue más
impresionante
y de pronto a partir de esta muerte ese
mismo día sentí la necesidad
de escribir yo ya escribía desde antes
ya republicadas no sé si díaz novelas
incluso una novela que escribimos
armando yo juntos pero fue una necesidad
orgánica una necesidad como de
supervivencia y le escribió una carta y
al día siguiente otra al otro día otra y
durante un mes y medio le escribí una
carta cada día y después una carta a la
semana una carta al mes y la novela que
yo estaba escribiendo en ese momento que
es mi más reciente novela que no tenía
nada que ver con armando de pronto sentí
la necesidad de meter armando como
personaje no es el protagonista pero ya
está hay un hilo conductor
con con armando y no es la relación que
tuvimos
eso me hizo darme cuenta con los días
algo que yo ya intuía que es que las
letras curan que la ficción cura
que la adicción nos enseña mucho más que
otras cosas mucho más que lo que
aprendemos en las aulas por ejemplo la
ficción una buena novela una novela que
nos habla de tu nos puede curar y
escribir también cura cuando me di
cuenta de esto
recordé también episodios de antes de
dos ejemplos tengo yo ahora una alumna
que en su momento no la conocía que me
cuenta puerto se acercó conmigo que
llevo un día en el coche oyó una
entrevista mía en el radio
freno se dio la vuelta y fue la librería
comprar la novela que estaba yo esté
anunciando llegó a su casa la leyó de un
tirón dice que la mitad de dio coraje y
la tiró la recogió terminó de leer la
novela
la dejo y dijo a ver si esto es lo que
siente mi marido no va a dejar a su
amante nunca y además yo quiero sentir
esto me quiero dar ese permiso fue al
estudio de su marido y le dijo mañana
mismo te vas de la casa quiero el
divorcio evidentemente en una relación
rota pero ella nunca se había atrevido a
pedir el divorcio cada vez que lo
enfrentaba él negaba que tuviera otra
otra persona que evidentemente sí la
tenía y hasta el día de hoy esta mujer
me da las gracias por las palabras que
escribe
hasta el día de hoy no solo me da las
gracias sino se metió a uno de mis
talleres de creación literaria porque
además ella siempre quiso ser escritora
y en la universidad de alguna maestra le
dijo nombre tú estás muy guapa y polonia
o que sirves es para salir en la tele tú
lo que tienes que hacer es conductor
pues ella decidió dejar al marido y
hacer lo que siempre había querido hacer
en todo el taller de creación literaria
ya publicó una novela y justo la semana
pasada terminó su segunda novela el otro
ejemplo de cómo las letras transforman y
cómo a veces no sabemos ni a quiénes les
llegan es esta carta que recibí me la
mandó la editorial está aquí adentro que
tengo una copia lo primero fue se me
hizo muy raro que fuera manuscrita
porque ya casi nadie escribe a mano no
les vale toda la carta pero me dicen
estimada señora rivas acabo de leer su
novela tal quería felicitarla portal y
me doy cuenta en la carta universal es
que está en español pero que es un
hombre culto me habla de libros en
alemán en inglés en francés en español
me dice yo estudié historia intelectual
de la europa moderna en washington
university
y universidad michigan escribió mi tesis
de doctorado sobre el concepto del
hombre alejandrino en la obra temprana
de nietzsche etcétera etcétera
trabajé como bibliotecario en new york
city y de pronto dice lamento mucho
tener que decirle yo dije dios seguro
metí la pata no investigue bien me va a
corregir pero no lamento mucho tener que
decirle que es que estoy actualmente
preso en el pabellón de la muerte aquí
en florida me hallo aquí porque maté a
mis ex novias gloria y lisa estoy
torturado por el remordimiento sé que ha
causado mucho mucho sufrimiento a las
familias de ellas no sé cuándo me van a
ejecutar pero sí sé que mi tiempo en
esta tierra es limitado viviendo noche y
tiene el confinamiento solitario no
tengo acceso a las librerías y las
bibliotecas por consiguiente me
considero un hombre de dicha cuando
logró conseguir un libro sobre la
historia intelectual su novela fue para
mí una piedra preciosa le agradezco
mucho por haberle escrito recibe el
respetuoso saludo de william code hay
preso l4 1976 unión correctional
institution
imagínense lo que yo sentí cuando leí
esta destacar también su darme cuenta
todavía más
de las letras y de que nunca sabemos a
quién a quién les llegan nuestros
nuestros libros nuestros escritos y
casualmente me regreso el día que murió
armando casualmente esa mañana tenía yo
mi primer taller de autobiografía ya
llevaba yo muchos años dando talleres
pero nunca de autobiografía a las dos
horas que muere armando que más bien que
me entero de su fallecimiento llegan mis
mis alumnas ni siquiera pensé no me
acordaba no les cancele y se me hizo una
grosería no dar la clase entonces me
senté como si nada hubiera pasado
y me sirvió también mucho les voy a
decir por qué porque cada una llevaba el
primer capítulo de lo que iba a ser una
novela sobre su vida es taller de
autobiografía de auto ficción y cuando
iban leyendo cosas terribles cosas de
perdidas de fracturas
de dolor de vacío primero dije pues
todos estamos iguales todos estamos
rotos agrietados tenemos nuestros y
nuestras grietas que hay que ir
reparando reparando con amor reparando
aceptando las no negando las y reparando
escribiendo ay me di cuenta del poder
que tiene la escritura para sanarnos
todas iban leyendo
es el único taller en que tengo que
poner yo este pañuelos deshechables en
medio porque de repente no pueden
terminar de leer y además me sentí en
conjunto dije no soy la única con una
perdida todos tenemos cargando este tipo
de pérdidas y de dolores y de duelo no
saben cómo me sirvió eso y no saben cómo
me sirvió todo lo que escribí todos los
días esa es mi propuesta es muy fácil mi
propuesta es no ver a la literatura no
ver a los libros como algo ajeno como
algo que solo pertenece a los
intelectuales o a las salas
universitarias como algo obligatorio
como algo frío mi propuesta es
precisamente abrazar las letras
hacerle el amor a los libros escoger el
libro que les hable a ustedes es
impresionante cómo funcionan los libros
uno abre un libro
y te llega el momento preciso no sé si
se les ha pasado en una frase que dicen
esta frase es lo que estoy sintiendo
ahora o esta frase me está hablando de
tu lean lean lean subrayan subrayan
subraya y escriban nuestro proponiendo
que todos aquí en este mundo nos
convirtamos en escritores que todo el
mundo publique pero escribir sana el
mundo de ficción aparentemente de
ficción porque el mundo de ficción tiene
a veces mucho más verdades que el mundo
real nos habla más directamente el mundo
de ficción sana escribir escribir su
vida escribir como si ustedes fueran un
personaje incluso pueden hasta cambiarle
el nombre para sentir esa lejanía
y para saber que pueden
verlo de otra manera y distanciarse
para observarse desde afuera y poderse
ir sanando realmente la escritura y las
letras que sanan y regreso a andré gide
este escritor francés con una frase que
me encanta para terminar esta
conversación y cuando te hayas leído
tires el libro y sal
quisiera que tu libro te proporcione el
anhelo de salir de tus miedos de tus
prejuicios de la parálisis para abrazar
la vida como algo que se ha estado a
punto de perder muchas gracias